[Music]
hello and welcome China's great over the
last two decades has been remarkable in
1995 its economy was half that of the UK
today it's six times the size for the
most part relations with the West have
been calm if not exactly friendly trade
wars with the United States to
saber-rattling in the South China Sea an
arms race in space there are increasing
tensions
not to mention new laws on hong kong
with the emergence of kovat 19
originally in china now causing
devastation around the globe the path to
a happy relationship with China looks
fraught with difficulty so should we
assume the transition to China's
economic dominance will be peaceful and
benign or will the transition improve
deeply unsettling for the world and
threaten its stability or should we see
China perhaps as a long-term ally or as
a potential threat to our way of life
well for this afternoon's debate we have
three eminently qualified speakers who
are going to debate be debating exactly
those questions first we have Sir
Malcolm Rifkind
former Secretary of State for defense
and foreign secretary in various
conservative governments and in fact as
foreign secretary he had the
responsibility of the final negotiations
with China over the transfer of hong
kong which has been very much in the
news in the past couple of days as we
record this debate he's both Queen's
Council and member of the Privy Council
then we have Isabel Hilton journalist
broadcaster and someone who has worked
for the Guardian the Sunday Times BBC
Radio 4 amongst a variety of
distinguished outlets she is also the
founding editor of China dialogue net
independent fully bilingual Chinese
English nonprofit organization devoted
to building a shared approach on climate
change and environmental issues with
China and last but by no means least
servants cable former leader of the
Liberal Democrats
served some two decades in Parliament in
the Twickenham constituency and former
cabinet member as Secretary of State for
Business Innovation and Skills from
10 2015 during the coalition government
so three very very well-informed and
distinguished speakers and we're going
to start by addressing a core question
at the heart of debate today's debate
which is should we view China as an ally
or as a threat I'm going to ask each of
our speakers today to address that
question for no more than three minutes
to give us their initial positions I'm
gonna start Malcolm Rifkind with you
Malcolm thank you very very much indeed
know the question of China a lie or a
threat is obviously in the context that
China is now one of the world
superpowers first point I want to make
is China should have been one of the
world's superpowers 40 years ago if it
hadn't been for the lunacy of Mugsy Tung
Cultural Revolution Great Leap Forward
and all these Marxist Leninist policies
China would have been way back in the
1960s or 70s how do we know that's not
just my theory look at other Chinese
communities Singapore Taiwan Hong Kong
all of whom were able to apply market
economics and as a result had a huge
level of prosperity which China has
caught up with the reason why China is
so noticeable is not because it's fun
some magic formula but because it has
1.3 billion people in a country of that
size which is economically successful of
course that has a powerful impact in the
world now is it an ally or a threat well
in the famous old saying it takes two to
tango we did believe until not too long
ago that China might gradually as it
emerged as a superpower and be a
responsible superpower one that would
try to work constructively not just with
the United States not just with the West
but with the same neighbors in the Far
East as well in in Asia and under dong
zhuo ping that was largely what was
happening as if that process began but
it ceased to happen sadly when Xi
Jinping the president leader took power
because I'm not going to comment on the
internal politics of China what I am
going to say is that what has been so
disturbing and so sad is it's not just
the round with America or the
disagreements that they have with
Britain or France or Germany or your
European Union he's
he's pursued a policy which is pagina in
conflict with its own immediate
neighbors try wannabes they're
threatening to embed under certain
circumstances and occurred apart from
Taiwan Japan South Korea Vietnam
virtually every neighborhood has right
through to India have become deeply
alarmed so ironic that Vietnam had once
the sworn enemy of the United States and
now sees America more as an ally than as
an enemy and China is the threat it
perceives recently India and Japan had a
joint naval exercise first time in their
history what an earth to India and Japan
have in common except that they both
have China as a neighbor
and they feel the need to draw together
so we used to talk about the Indian
Ocean and the Pacific Ocean now it's
called the Indo Pacific it's a single
region which has come into geopolitical
language because of the concern about
China let me make the final point in
these introductory and comments and that
is simply I hope we China will change
course to last week's events on Hong
Kong deeply disturbing we might discuss
these later on but if China continues
its current course of confrontation with
its own neighbors as well as the West
then we will need a policy of
containment so what we had with the
Soviet Union and the bad old days during
the Cold War I do think we'll have a
Cold War but I think we will have
containment unless China behaves in a
more responsible fashion
welcome Rifkin thank you very much for a
very clearly put first position there
and can outturn Isabel Hilton to you
Isabel
thank you and Rana well Ally or threat
it's one of those binaries I think I
prefer the European councils formulation
that China is both a strategic rival and
an economic partner and it's difficult
say never to anything in this world and
I did have to remind myself that the
Soviet Union was an ally during World
War two as I was thinking it's hard to
imagine China ever being a strategic or
military ally so one should never say
never but it is very very hard to
imagine and but that is not to say that
we can't make allowance alliances or
or indeed cooperate on certain issues
with China and the critical one is
obviously climate change where China is
buying far and away the biggest emitter
of greenhouse gases and if we believe
that climate change is an existential
threat then we have to cooperate with
China that could take many forms and but
if we don't then you know all the other
questions we're discussing here will be
irrelevant and so the degree to which
China is a threat in some ways I think
but again I prefer the formulation that
China is threatening some important
things rather than that China is in
itself one big comprehensive threat for
a number of reasons but first what China
is threatening I agree with Markham you
know very disturbing things on the South
China Sea very bad atmosphere in the
neighborhood very very concerning about
hong kong cyber warfare those things
that we're familiar with but i would
also like to point to the fact that
among China's ambitions is the ambition
to become a normative power and this is
visible in everything from its external
propaganda its conduct in academia its
efforts to change the language and
values of the United Nations and
generally you know to challenge the
liberal order and indeed on the material
side to set standards for advanced
technologies which would certainly give
China a lot of power and if China were
to succeed in becoming that kind of
normative power then we're looking at a
world that is run according to Chinese
rules and I think that is threatening
it's threatening two fundamental values
and and it's writing obviously too you
know Western dominance in certain areas
of technology but if you like that's
fair enough
but I don't think that allows one to
define China you know simply as a threat
and one reason is that I think China is
facing a lot of internal problems and
that China's capacity to fulfill these
ambitions is going to be increasingly
compromised particularly after after the
pandemics so again it's a fairly
familiar list big domestic problems
unemployment data aging population
slowing growth political legitimacy all
of these are really going to keep I
think Beijing desperately steering the
ship and trying to avoid the immediate
rocks rather than being able to fulfill
any sort of great dreams of global
domination if there is a threat in this
situation I think that what we've
learned recently is that we have allowed
ourselves to become dependent in ways
that are undermining our own security
and that that needs correcting that's
not quite the same as seeing China as a
threat as well thank you very much again
a very clearly put position there and
Myrna call on Vince Cable to make your
answer to the question of China a loyal
threat Vince well my position isn't too
different from Isabelle's I mean it's
it's it's not a threat to the UK maybe a
threat to its neighbors I know it's
certainly not a threat to the UK
militarily or in any obvious security
sense we have a lot of common interest
in the economics field we I was part of
the government which developed the
so-called golden era that mr. that that
was before president G was so powerful
but we also have much better commonality
of interests in areas like the future of
the World Trade Organization or climate
changed and we do with the United States
which is supposed to be one of our
allies so you know we shouldn't be
consumed with negativity and I and I do
worry that we have got this almost
paranoia business developed about China
which has been manifest in areas like
Iowa to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas